make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so getting into batman/superman
number one right the story of the Shazam
whoo laughs this is a really really cool
story because this fits in nicely with
Scout Snyder's Dark Knight's in metal
know with Williamson I don't really
worry about making sure things fit into
continuity but there are riders where
you do kind of worry about that right
for those of you guys who are finishing
Superman unity saga the witch will
actually do the second video or yes the
first part of the conclusion will do
that today as well
yeah Brian Michael Bendis just kind of
Yanks out an ending out of nowhere and
it's weird part of ending out of nowhere
and it's like it's the day is saved it
was kind of like okay you know but with
William so I never really worry about
that with a lot of riders when they do
tie intra they do you like a follow up
to an event the lantern like start
crafting a story and change things
almost like they're they're generally
aware of the original story but never
actually read it and that's one of the
things that I was the you know that that
that there is pause to be concerned for
but again with Williamson we don't
really worry about those kinds of things
right I mean you guys an outstanding
writer the guy keeps everything in
continuity I definitely dig his work and
so what this does is it initially takes
place in the dark multiverse itself and
it picks up basically with Superman now
of course Superman is summoned to the
Justice League Watchtower basically by
Batman and again this works really
really well because when it comes to
Batman of Superman they're kind of the
one-two punch of the comic book
community right I mean when I say come
in the community I mean like in general
including Marvel DC like valiant the
whole nine yards like they are the
one-two punch in so far is like they're
the two guys right like the two guys
that you always call when Batman is
Superman team-up then you usually get
spectacular stories out of it because
it's brain and brawn and so when this
takes place and when Superman blight
actually gets out there he gets into the
watchtower only to find that basically
everybody's been killed this is a cool
thing is because if you remember during
the Batman who laughs one-shot comic the
tie-in to Dark Knight's metal that gave
us his origin story this is what he did
right we don't really know exactly how
he did it we just know he did that he
went through and essentially like like
kill all the members of the Justice
League right so like like Hawkman
Hawkgirl and then you have like Martian
Manhunter and you've got Wonder Woman
and the flash their body like they're
all literally just dead and when
Superman had walked into the watchtower
because of the fact that the whole place
had been flooded with a kryptonite
gasped he was immediately dying right
like he was immediately the end of him
like like this whole place is flooded
with kryptonite gas there's no way for
you to get out of here you're going to
die and so it's kind of a precursor to
everything right because we know that
following this little this little bit of
an introduction that in turn what he'd
done is he had kidnapped Jonathan Kent
and Lois Lane and the
brought them to the watchtower and then
infected both Jonathan Kent and Superman
with black kryptonite which of course
drove them insane and they tore Lois
Lane apart and so it's kind of
interesting because this was really done
to incapacitate Superman they didn't
really lead to his immediate death but
like it was designed to incapacitate
Superman and then turn him into his
darker self by using black kryptonite
and the whole reason why the Batman who
lasted this was because he was kind of
like I was just curious I was just
curious what you would be like if you
were like your darker self again it's
really twisted and it's really more
screwed up but what this does is it
jumps to earth zero now this is where
the main story basically begins to pick
up and what you have here is is
Commissioner Gordon summoning Batman
himself now when he summons him Batman
also does sort of kind of talks right at
Commissioner Gordon thinks he's talking
to him but Batman is basically running
over everything that had happened since
the events of Dark Knight's metal then
after that story where it seemed like
all the Dark Knight's had basically been
defeated the Batman who laughs survived
and then kind of started going through
with this campaign to try to make Batman
into his darker self to kind of present
this idea that Batman could only ever be
happy if he basically gave into his
darker side right so very similar to The
Killing Joke right the Joker's desire to
show it all it takes is one bad day for
a person to snap and become just like
him now of course it didn't work for
Batman he ended up staying and and
becoming a good guy you know I guess
staying a good guy and in sting his
normal self as we saw during the the the
was a Batman who lost parts one through
seven full story but basically he's
running over all this and explaining it
all to Superman and that's kind of a
funny thing here is because you would
expect that Superman would know all of
this right I mean we know that at the
end of the Batman who lost that he's
basically stuck in the basement of the
Hall of Justice and he's being held
prisoner there but just because he's
there doesn't mean the suit that Batman
explained to everything to Superman and
it could be the Batman just took him
there and threw him in right because any
member of the Justice League can access
the Hall of Justice right I mean they're
part and parcel to the team they can
come and go as they please and so it's a
cool little bit of a thing here because
basically all this stuff that sort of
explained to to Superman in so far as
like the danger of an alternate reality
version where there's a Batman who has
all this intelligence and all the
Joker's insanity and can use that to
achieve whatever goal he wants now the
meat-and-potatoes for why it is that
that commissioner gordon's summoned
Batman here and really Superman by
extension is because there's a little
kid named Danny miles that's gone
missing right he's been missing for a
little while his parents are freaking
out and it's hey Batman like we needed
we needed to you know to be sorted out
and Batman summons Superman here to base
talk to him in to help him with this
case now one of the cool things about
this is that this is actually the first
time in the history of really since the
b-52 that Superman has met Jim Gordon is
a pretty awesome little moment to go on
here
not as messing around somebody somewhere
out there somebody is furiously typing
away on their keyboard like freaking out
not true
I found something Rob is wrong about
yeah like it's it's it's interesting
there's nobody losing it right now but
the whole reason why Superman was
summoned here by Batman is because this
is kind of Williamson touching on Tower
of Babel and it's cool right he doesn't
explicitly say it and even in the
aftermath of tower Babel while it wasn't
referenced all the time like the stage
had basically been set this idea that
Batman had protocols to take out each
member of the Justice League if they
lost their mind and they went rogue and
that's kind of what William said a hit
song right like Batman literally asked
Superman do you have protocols on what
would happen if I became evil like if
I'd lost my mind and decided to take
everybody out are there any protocols
there like do you have any way to make
sure that I wouldn't use anything
against you and it's kind of a funny
thing because at the outset you would
think well yeah I mean Superman's
protocol is to just punch Batman's head
off right let me just say it's like mr.
Sunday movie said like all the ways to
gramatica kill Batman right like like do
this thing and then kick his head off
like or punch his head off or like rip
his head off or something like that like
all the different ways to pull that off
which is actually a pretty amazing video
you guys should all go watch that but
the fact remains it's Batman sort of
asking the question what are you guys
going to do if a time comes when with
all my knowledge and all my
understanding of your weaknesses and
your strengths I basically go crazy and
I decided to take all of you got all of
you guys out and the response is ooh man
really seems to be we don't have one
because we trust you and that's cool and
everything but you always need to make
sure that you have apparently like a
plan right like it ruins the Justice
League have to have that because you're
talking about people who are exceedingly
powerful or capable in their own right
Batman's not really powerful it does it
really possess any powers but between
his intellect and and all his knowledge
on the members of the Justice League he
could bring them down quick fast and in
a hurry that was the nature of Tower of
Babel right like all these different
protocols that were set up to
incapacitate each member of the league
in case they went awry or or whatever
the case was for a Superman that kind of
respond like that almost really seems
naive like what if the most intelligent
member of your superhero team and indeed
probably one of the most intelligent
members of the of like the planet Earth
short of maybe Lex Luthor basically
awarded
into a villain with all its knowledge
about you you have no safeguard for that
like you have no way to protect yourself
from that that's how the Batman who
laughs won presumably is because his
whole league trusted him and there's
something to be said about trusting him
there's also something to be saying
about being foolish about not really
taking the steps you need to in order to
make sure that you and yours are safe
right because more important than any
individual in the Justice League is
safeguarding the earth itself and
ensuring the league's survival that
supersedes everything right so you kind
of have to make sure all that is set in
stone now when this happens of course
they end up travelling down with a
scrape a huge hole where where it seems
as though Danny miles has basically gone
to or at least where it seems like a
place where he would have been taken and
when they get there of course there's
all these mech BOTS essentially that
were brought in here by the Batman who
laughs and they're all taken out pretty
easily what this does is this leads into
essentially like this big makeshift
place where the Batman who last was
operating out of and it's not really
even makeshift I mean it's built and
designed pretty well but with a Batman
who lasts and the grim night were
functioning that's what this sits and
this is a cool thing because we never
really saw the tried and true lair of
the Batman who lives right we never
really saw the tried and true lair of
where he worked out of we know he did
and we saw a little glimpses here in
there but it's cool to essentially see
the whole thing well it's cool to see
like this entire thing in terms of where
he was functioning and what he was doing
but like all these difference you don't
like like battering malls all these
different things all these devices were
designed for the purpose of having
essentially remnants of the map Batman
who lost serum as well as things like
green kryptonite to take out Superman
and so it's obvious the plan of the
Batman who lost was much grander than
simply just incapacitating Batman it
would have put two queens in the
chessboard no pun intended because what
you would have had is a Batman who
laughs who has all these all the
intelligence of Batman and all the
insanity of the Joker who in turn brings
the main DC Universe Batman over to his
side you've got to evil Batman running
around a universe they would decimate
all everybody would fall fall prey to
them and so what this does is it almost
leads to a kind of game right there's
this chessboard that's basically set up
between the white in the black side and
the way the pieces are arranged no side
can move without the other winning right
so like if the black side moves a piece
white wins if white moves a piece black
wins right just because of the way that
the chess set is set up and so as a
result of this it's kind of like well
what if we move a piece like let's just
see what happens and when they do it
ends up basically bringing this giant
image of all the different members of
the superhero community when I say all I
mean all of them every single member of
the superhero community and the idea is
they're all they've all day
we've been Joker eyes meaning they're
all a target for the Batman who laughs
serum right for the you know to
basically turn them off into villains
and so it's kind of cool because when
that happens suddenly the two of the
were met by the year by by one of the
crows of the Batman who laughs now these
crows were always ambiguous and really
it wasn't even like Scott Snyder never
really even gave us in the indication of
what they were you know when this story
was initially announced it was funny
because I saw people who are complaining
about the fact that like why is he why
is you know Joshua Williamson changing
these crows to be what they are to make
him into his own thing but that's funny
like Snyder never told us what they were
the fan base assumed what they were and
then took that assumption as fact as it
was it's interesting right because I
mean we do that all the time
but it's it's sort of it's sort of
intriguing there so the result is that
we basically have this this crow who you
know of course a tax batman and then
basically starts talking to the two of
them and saying that like did that man
who last took this this kid from his
family and and basically hit him with a
Batarang that turned him into the person
that he has now turned him into a crow
that he changed this kid into what he is
forced him to start wearing this this
costume and basically like you know used
him in the various missions that he had
and so where you have Superman who
addresses this kid as as Danny miles the
kid says you don't understand I'm not
Danny miles like he took me like that
many laughs took me from where I was and
freed me like I'm not upset about where
I am I'm not sad about being where I am
I don't want to go back home like I'm
free like like do you guys not recognize
me
my name is Billy Batson and so this is
crazy because what we get is the Shazam
who lasts and this is awesome because
Billy in turn shouts the word Shazam and
then basically like becomes this insane
powerhouse and ask the question I always
wondered what it would be like to beat
the crap out of Superman and actually
what he's got in his hand is to stab him
with one of the one of the Batman who
laughs batteries this is amazing because
like the notion of a Shazam whoo laughs
right I mean you know Saran who laughs
would be cool but Shazam is a fan
favorite you guys love him and so let
you take like Shazam and then you turn
him into basically like a bad man who
lost character oh it's beast it's
amazing but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments
explained to make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the rod for
if you guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]